all right gary yes gary oh where'd you
go where are you from originally i grew
up in oregon well actually i was born in
new york i lived in uh my dad was in the
air force in the army we so we moved a
lot i lived in hawaii until i was on my
sixth birthday i was on a plane to
orange county
and i lived in orange county until
i was 25 i moved up here
to l.a yeah and uh tell me about your
family growing up you had mom and dad
yeah uh i had a mom and dad obviously
and a brother and sister
my parents divorced when i was five um
some inappropriate stuff
happening between my sister and my dad
unfortunately
and so my mom divorced my dad and we
moved to
uh my dad kind of bailed out on my mom
so we ended up moving to orange county
with my mom
and uh when i was about six years old
she started dropping the ball so to
speak
and she's an alcoholic and we ended up
in foster homes oh really yeah actually
on my sixth birthday i got they caught
me at a liquor store and my brother and
sister are older than me they had me in
my mom's coat stealing at a store and we
didn't have any supervision so they took
us away put us in foster rooms and uh
that was kind of the beginning of that
cycle how would you describe your
your experience with the foster system
my well i was in a lot of foster homes
yeah some temporary ones some good ones
some bad ones
some abusive ones
you know like for example i kind of i
wet my bed
a lot when i was young and i had a
foster home foster parents that would
abuse me basically when i would
wet my bed and when my social worker got
a hold of that she took me out of there
and put me in a home where they rewarded
me when i didn't wet my bed so it was
kind of like
yeah some good experiences good homes
and bad homes
yeah yeah i remember actually uh
a foster home that i was in where
they had a real daughter and she was
like a real brat and i used to like do
things to try to get her to to entertain
her to keep her from running to her her
parents and like getting me in trouble
and actually broke this finger actually
doing somersaults trying to
trying to you know keep her quiet
basically and when i when showed them
the finger she told me i'll go run it
under cold water
and this is the result oh yeah and when
i showed that to my social worker she
took me out of there that day
so the the turmoil
yeah it was they were abusive but with
the unsettled without a doubt life you
had as a kid but it must have paid it
was it was it was yeah it was a lot
yeah it really was
and where did your life go after
after that well
um like 18
huh did that end at 18 um well basically
by the time i was 13 i i was pretty much
back in my mom's custody
yeah and so i was running the streets
basically with my older brother and uh
started doing crystal when i was 13.
actually shot up crystal for the first
time when i was 13. and i had a sugar
daddy for the first time when i was 13
as well
yeah oh really yeah i was very mature i
grew up very very fast
but at that point i got on probation so
i would end up in group homes as opposed
to foster homes when my mom would drop
the ball so
that cycle continued until i was 18.
where where do you think you learned
that sex was a commodity that you could
sell pretty young like i said 12 or 13
hours where did you learn it well i was
hitchhiking around orange county and
guys would pick me up and
that's when i met this jeweler guy he
owned the jewelry store in anaheim and
he wrote his number on a 50 bill
and he should take me to palm springs
and like take me around to all his
friends and
be like guess how old gary is you know
and they'd be like oh eight because i
looked older they'd be like 18 19. he'd
be like 13 they'd be like
you know they're they're relieved yeah
really
yeah
and i pretty much continue doing that i
would pick it up and put it down a lot
in the prostitution part
but until i was basically affordable
you know i did it on different levels
but i would get involved with guys and
you know we would take care of each
other's needs as opposed to me like
being out there all the time
that was kind of my fortune yeah
so today you're living where
right now i live
i live up the street at the lincoln
hotel which is a skid row housing trust
right i've been there for a while but i
got a lot of problems there in fact uh
somebody just lit my apartment on fire
like two nights ago
they're trying to get me out of the
building why is that
i'm not sure exactly they want my
apartment um i had some problems with
this company like some years back
but it's really a long story it's
complicated so even getting housing on
skid row is
it
is a drama valuable thing and i'm trying
to hold on to it and i've done pretty
good you know 14 years there's nothing
to shake a stick oh you've been there
for 14 years yeah and now they're doing
these kind of things and yeah yeah two
nights ago they they lit my apartment on
fire
they yeah
and uh
your your crystal matthews has continued
is what you're you're still using yeah i
use it i smoke it
i don't i don't shoot i used to shoot
but i don't know what is what does
crystal meth do for you it uh
basically gets me out of bed i mean
it's just a daily thing for me now it
makes me like
sexual too it's a sexual thing yeah i've
heard that from a lot of guys yeah i i
don't hear from women but i hear from
guys really
yeah it gives me energy i'm sure it
doesn't bother me it doesn't do anything
i don't get real paranoid or anything
like that
sometimes you get a little like
speedy
but that's about it yeah yeah
and the quality is not what it used to
be right no
it's not the same as it used to be years
ago you could stay up for five six days
i sleep every night
you know but yeah it's not like it was
but
are you worried that you're putting
things in your body that are just
garbage
yeah i care a lot about myself and about
my health
i really actually do but at the same
time
it's so unregulated at the same time you
know i've been positive for a long long
time and i saw back in the day when i
got my diagnosis we
didn't think we'd be around
this long so i started making peace with
all that a long time ago oh so you're
hiv positive i've been positive since 91
well yeah and you seem very healthy
thank you
yeah i'm pretty healthy i am pretty up
there there's medications that you take
and things like that that yeah i take it
take two i take um
the newest one whatever it's called and
they do another one on top of it
uh
that one's a daily pill yeah
is there any are there any side effects
or anything i don't really experience
any i haven't really experienced any um
no
fortunately not for me it's just taking
them is the big
you know the biggest component because i
have a tendency not to because i'm so i
feel healthy
so i just i'm like yeah so there's a gay
bath house that's right down the corner
i live right like a stone's throw from
that bath house right across the street
do you ever go there i used to go there
i haven't been there for years what kind
of stuff happens there
oh spawn stuff
you know
it's like you go in there and you just
you really don't you just get stuck
but you know it's a lot of just second
and [ __ ] you know
it's and a lot of crystal meth
yeah everybody's using in there they
used to be pretty like more relaxed
about it but now they're starting to get
more
you know they just check your bags and
[ __ ] but
i mean if you're going to stay there all
night i think you would need something
like that too huh if you're going to
stay oh yeah and most people that go
there are on but
you know is it is it a popular drug
among the in the gay community oh yeah i
think it is it's like the staple you
know
it really is yeah
i think more people do it than don't you
know
i would say is that right yeah
yeah
but the smart ones you know come out the
other side and
yeah yeah
and i mean did you have dreams of doing
something with your life i mean rather
than ending up here on skid row uh i did
um you've had jobs huh you've had jobs
oh many different kinds of jobs i've
done yeah i'm actually the last thing i
got certified as a medical
transcriptionist
but it was right around the time when
voice rec software came out and
unfortunately i didn't do the
forecasting and neither did my uh rehab
counselor and so i got certified like
right at the time that the industry
crashed so i never actually got any work
doing that but i have administrative
skills i was a bartender
did construction work uh all kinds of
work i was a driver first call driver
for
the coroner lots of different jobs how
old do you know
i'm 40 or 54. i just turned 54 last week
yeah i mean
would you prefer to be living a
different life where you're not down
here and
perhaps they're working or
i you can tell well you know it's a good
question but
some people are content here i i am
content i'm fortunate like i said that i
have a place
um
i don't have a lot of real solid
drive toward any particular thing that's
kind of i you know i feel like i'm kind
of doing what i'm supposed to be doing
in a way because i'm one of the few
people in my building that's like
has
the characteristics that i do
there yeah and i think that i'm trying
to like be an example and a lot of
people aren't picking it up and it's
kind of frustrating
you know as yeah
do you have friends
i have a few
a few
yeah but my friends don't really
necessarily like my decisions so
you know
i kind of like you know lead your life
and i'll leave mine and
at the end of the day i care about you
but you know
what would you say is your biggest
regret
my biggest regret
probably ever starting drugs i think
because i really i don't know that's
that's a tough one though because
it's not realistic i don't think
i mean
give me the biggest regret giving your
childhood though that kind of stuff our
biggest regret probably is just
not believing myself the whole way
through you know what i mean
not knowing that
knowing my potential
and you know
not believing in yourself and yeah
exactly
because if i didn't know them what i
know now you know what i mean if i
hadn't known i was going to be here this
long i would have planned better and
you know what i mean right yeah
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life uh
most important lesson would be
uh
i think you know i've kind of always
known everything in my heart that i
needed to know
i feel like
the lesson
just to value people more i would say
you know and not to take my anger out on
people probably because i have a
tendency to lash out
yeah i still do
yeah because i get frustrated when
people don't i don't get what i want
from people
i start lashing out
you know
all right well gary thank you so much
for talking with me no problem man i
wish you the best of luck all right
thank you thank you all right
you